comment google s'y prend-il pour
améliorer son empreinte carbone réponse
avec sébastien missoffe directeur
général de google pour la france bonjour
bonjour des villes va très bien merci
alors google vise le zéro carbone d'ici
2030 ça signifie qu'à cette échéance là
vous n'utiliserez plus aucune énergies
fossiles gaz pétrole ou charbon pour
alimenter à la fois vos bureaux voler ta
center mais il ya déjà un bout du chemin
qui a été fait j'imagine alors c'est un
gros bout d'ailleurs très importants' de
ré expliquer cela dans le contexte en
effet c'est un engagement qui a commencé
il ya longtemps c'est un engagement qui
a commencé il ya quinze ans qu en 2007
google avait annoncé la carboneutralité
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait compenser
autant de l'énergie carbonique que nous
compensions c puis la neutralité
maintenant c'est zéro carbone et alors
qu'est la part du chemin qui a été fait
aujourd'hui revenons sur exactement à
quoi sert cet important en tant
qu'utilisateur qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement ça veut dire qu'en
2030 l'engagement est qu'à chaque fois
que vous faites une recherche sur google
chaque fois que vous regardez une vidéo
sur youtube à chaque fois que vous
envoyez un email ça va chercher des
informations sur des data center et que
100 % de l'énergie qui viennent
alimenter ses datacenter soient
alimentaires avec de l'énergie
décarbonée la cclat aujourd'hui on a
combien de tirs se sent aujourd'hui on
est à peu près à deux tiers dans le
monde et en europe on a déjà cinq
datacenter qui soit plus de 90% et
aujourd'hui pas d'électricité à base de
charbon il ya encore un petit peu alors
c'est vraiment au cas par cas
pas ces éléments de réponse là non mais
au niveau global en effet on est à deux
tiers d'énergie des câbles pour arriver
à ce 100% d'énergies vertes et ce zéro
carbone ça sera encore difficile les
deux tiers du chemin qui reste à
parcourir à l'évêque de l'innovation
avec
votre la dernière partie est évidemment
la partie la plus difficile la première
partie et on le voit c'est facile
d'avoir de l'énergie décarbonée un corps
ya du soleil quand il ya du vent la
difficulté est un homme intelligent il y
en a pas tout le temps et que c'est
difficile de stocker cette information
donc pour y arriver il ya deux grandes
briques la première brique ces
désinvestissements
il n'y a pas suffisamment aujourd'hui
d'énergie décarbonée pour pouvoir venir
fournir l'énergie à tous et de ta center
et donc c'est de continuer à investir
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
ces 6 milliards d'euros qui ont été
investis pour mettre plus de ces
énergies là aujourd'hui sur le marché on
a annoncé l'année dernière pour
l'allemagne que ont signé un grand
partenariat avec angie avec de l'énergie
éolienne et solaire en plus ce qui nous
permettra d'arriver cette année en
allemagne à 80 % d'énergies décarbonées
dans nos structures en a marre est donc
le premier enjeu c'est l'investissement
et le deuxième c'est l'innovation c'est
la technologie pour la technologie
qu'est ce que c'est c'est de faire en
sorte avec l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on arrive avec des calculs plus
rapide aujourd'hui pour un même calcul
on arrive est cette fois plus efficace
que ce qu'on était il ya cinq ans on
essaye de faire en sorte sur b
calcul des machine learning qui n'ont
pas besoin d'être fait à une aire
spécifique si vous cherchez un mot si on
a besoin de rajouter des mots
spécifiques pour google traduction on va
utiliser le moment où on est sûr d'avoir
de l'énergie décarbonée en abondance
pour utiliser ce moment là donc choisir
les bons moments de la journée et enfin
énormément d'investissement sur des
batteries pour mieux signifier c'est
énerve la fabrication d'un d'un serveur
ça concentrent 80% de la facture
énergétique
d'où la question que je me posais c'est
est-ce que vous communiquer sur l'impact
carbone de vaud datacenter sur
l'ensemble du cycle de vie et pas
uniquement au moment où vous les
utilisez est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous regardez sur lequel vous
communiquer alors on pourra regarder
j'ai pas les chiffres je ne sais pas
quelle est la source des chiffres que
vous évoquez mais ce que vous évoquez
qui est la question évidemment
fondamental sur ce sujet si les
différents visuels on doit s'engager le
niveau 1 et au terme de consommation de
l'énergie évidemment aussi les 2 et 3
sur lequel on doit s'engager dans un
télescope de l aise comme trois
exactement savoir encore une fois sur le
de l'ensemble du cycle de vie l'énergie
on a utilisé pour fabriquer un
datacenter ou pour le détruire derrière
eskom 3c lusage des clients et des
fournisseurs pardon être précis sur vous
êtes imbattable
sur ces sujets et donc sur ce sujet là
sur ce point sur les autres scoops on
s'engage cette net neutralité c'est à
dire de compenser en termes d'énergie ce
qui a été utilisé pour la fabrication
ses datacenter l'impact environnemental
d'un datacenter ça serait une pas
évidemment uniquement sa facture
d'électricité est aussi une grosse
consommation d'eau ça on le sait elle
augmente aussi rapidement votre
consommation d'eau et quel impact vous
regarder l'impact s'assure sur les sols
sur la faune sur l'affluence et lorsque
vous regardez sur lequel vous
communiquer aussi l'eau est utilisé
aujourd'hui pour refroidir les data
center sur ça ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est d'abord de voir que
chaque datacenter des réponses un peu
différente ça dépend de nous on est si
on arrive à récolter des autres pluie
quel type dos rond peut utiliser et sur
cet engagement spécifique autour de
l'eau notre engagement est de faire en
sorte qu'on remet 120% de ce qu'on a
consommé c'est à dire plus d'eau dans le
système avec des accords qu'on fait
localement avec des stations d'épuration
pour remettre plus de dents dans
l'écosystème alors entre zéro carbone
c'est l'objectif évidemment et donc
utiliser des sources d'électricité
éolienne ou solaire pour alimenter les
serveurs il faut ce qu'on appelle des
métaux stratégiques il faut du lithium
du cuivre du cobalt dont l'extraction on
le sait porte atteinte à la biodiversité
à l'environnement vous vous assurez vous
chez google que tous ces mets ton était
extrait de manière durable de manière
responsable vous regardez ça aussi oui
alors on a un certain nombre de chartes
avec chacun des fournisseurs avec lequel
on travaille qui est un point important
et puis les engage avec un engagement et
ensuite ce qui est important aussi de
réfléchir à la durée de vie
par exemple sur les téléphones qui est
un engagement sur lequel on travaille
mais ce qui est très important c'est de
faire en sorte que quand vous achetez un
téléphone on puisse continuer à mettre
les mises à jour des différents software
pendant au moins cinq ans qui contribua
à permettre aux utilisateurs de
conserver choix à conserver leur jeter
entre guillemets la rejeter exactement
il trouve que tout est conservé on le
sait dans les datacenter nos vieux mail
datant de 20 ans une vidéo de chat qu'on
a fait qu'on a posté sur youtube il ya
dix ans est ce que on sait que tout ce
stockage ça consomme de l'énergie
sébastien missoffe pour tout ça pour une
utilité qui est discutable il ya des bas
mais c'est vrai est ce que vous regardez
ça aussi longtemps des consommateurs le
souhaite mais ce que c'est vraiment
important de conserver sa aussi
longtemps vous ouvrez votre compte gmail
vous pouvez voir combien d'informations
sont stockés tous ces éléments là nous
aide à faire des choix rationnels mais
toutes
ces chiffres que nous partageons nous
permettent ensuite c'est comme ça quand
les responsabiliser quelque part les
utilisateurs en montrant voilà voilà
tout ce stockage que ça coûte en
électricité en faire c'est hors de nous
voir le stocker les informer et les
responsabiliser et ensuite de l'autre
côté en termes de technologie être
capable d'être créatif de continuer à
investir ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure sur la puissance de calcul qui
nous permet de stocker ces informations
avec de moins en moins d'énergie et ça
fait changer les comportements c'est
suffisant pour faire évoluer les
comportements ou c'est pas votre rôle
encore une fois l'idée c'est d'éduquer
entre guillemets à la une forme de
sobriété numérique en matière de
pollution ce que c'est il ya une
pollution qui est lié à au numérique est
source de solutions qui est source de
pollution parce que la vie n'est pas
pénible en chinois alors sur la
pollution numérique est vraiment pour
moi ces deux jambes sur lesquels il faut
marcher la première s'est en effet
montré les utiliser aux études yater
quel est l'impact c'est un travail
d'éducation qui vraiment absolument
important et puis la deuxième la
technologie peut aussi aider à cette
sobriété numérique sauf qu'un des
exemples est plus intéressant c'est que
si vous regardez aujourd'hui une vidéo
sur youtube selon vous la regardiez chez
vous sur du wifi ou sur du 4k dans un
métro on va savoir adapter la qualité de
la vidéo en fonction de là où vous êtes
du type d' usage de l'écran que vous
regardez et donc de contribuer à cette
sobriété numérique allez merci beaucoup
sébastien missoffe directeur général de
google france merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]